i'm stefan letourneau i'm executive vp
in charge of two portfolios corporate
affairs which includes legal affairs
and partnerships
[Music]
it was just a
growth on steroids so we had one
employee in 2018 we now have senate we
had seven profs we now have 70. we had
probably 50 students we now have more
than 700 we didn't have space we shared
offices on campus we now have 92 000
square feet that we lease and
we had a couple of companies a handful
of companies and now we have
more than 80 industry collaborators
the scientific excellence of our
professors is
recognized worldwide and they draw to
them the best students from everywhere
in the world and those students are
work a workforce
for research projects and then even a
labor force when they graduate and the
there was a snowball effect of course
because the giant the technological
giants were first movers but then the
attention got going and montreal it just
had a snowball effect as i said montreal
got to be an epicenter of ai drawing
talents from everywhere and companies
from everywhere
recently a company from the midwest in
the states
decided was looking for a place to
establish its basis on the eastern front
of
the americas and they chose toronto for
their
for their office but montreal for their
ai laboratory
mila so that's that's one i think
example that speaks volume and another
point another anecdotal evidence of that
is for instance sweden recently decided
to establish
an antenna here they will send an
employee of their ai sweden group which
is a the um
the group that looks to
facilitate the adoption of ai in
industry so i think miele will not
necessarily grow its footprint but it
will certainly
improve and augment its impact in
specific in several fields
one for sure is ai in health
we have a lot of professors
that have an interest in health already
what needs to be done is to organize
them to add funding to the field to
bring in more companies and to create
really
an ecosystem around ai and health
itself so that's one field of growth in
terms of impact and activity
another one if we play our cards right
would be environment so we have
excellent professors in the field
and it's certainly a field that's dying
to
draw more advantages from the
machine learning
and the entire planet would benefit so
that's certainly something we're looking
at and then finally i would say
assisting working with smes
with applied workshops in machine
learning for instance
there's a lot of
useful
assistance that we can bring to the
general economic
ecosystem that we haven't we have shied
from doing so far what makes me proud is
the
feeling that i'm contributing to
building a huge
center of excellence that will be a
legacy to future generations